all right let's go to katie in dickinson
north dakota
katie good morning how are you i'm doing
well how are you john
good good good how can i help you this
morning
well i was calling because a couple
years ago ryan and i
my husband and i we uh went through a
really tough time
we moved out to this rural place in
north dakota and i just
started living this kind of single life
even though we were still married and
um what does that mean what does that
mean what does that mean
uh just like so he was working nights
and i
had a bunch of time to myself i was
working remotely i didn't get a lot of
adult interaction so
i picked up like an extra job and i was
after my job i would go out every night
and i would
stay out late and i was
you know making friends with guys and
even though it was platonic like
i didn't understand how
i don't know i guess irresponsible or
not okay that was
um and so he there's a lot of trust
issues
uh just because then he was kind of
trying to forbid me to hang out with
these guys and i didn't really get
get it and how important it was to him
and so i
i just didn't stop and we would you know
go play basketball and then go hit the
bars and go
play volleyball and then you know have
something to drink and
it was just did you ever cheat on him
yeah it was
i did not so that's one thing is that
while
no infidelity occurred you know he was
still
as broken as if it did occur and
after this time we had a certain amount
of time i can't remember if it was six
months
you know we we finally got to this
breaking point where
i think it hit me and we went to a
counselor and we saw a good priest
and over time i would say about two
years ago now we
we got to a point where we were whole
again and
while while it still hurts for him so
this is why i'm calling because
you know we you know couples fight so a
couple days ago a fight
happened and he brought up you know
stuff that happened
you know six months ago eight months ago
two years ago
and he brings it into current fights and
while i want to be understanding
of his wounds and i totally know i i
heard him and he's got he still has
these trust issues not only with me but
his past relationships
you know how can i be understanding and
listen
and be a good wife
and and um and listen you know and not
but not dwell on these past issues i
mean i don't want to live in the past
because i really didn't like how ugly of
a person i was but i have to know that
that's still so
fresh in his mind and those probably
trust issues are going to come up for a
while yet
and how do we work around this or how
how can i be
be more understanding of this while not
oh yeah just dwelling on that person i
was i i think
number one you've got to forgive
yourself
and if your husband threw time with a
counselor through time with
just time separate right for a couple of
years since then
if your husband's forgiven you if you
sat with your pastor your priest and
he said he forgives you you've got to
forgive you number one
number two fights and painful moments
man they dredge up old stuff and things
come
firing out of us sometimes um and you've
got to give
him some grace too but at the same time
he's if he said he forgives you and he
said
he's ready to work on the marriage
mirror just two years ago and y'all are
whole and you're moving forward
then you're whole and you're moving
forward and so at some point he's got to
stop weaponizing the past also
right now i'm telling you that to tell
you this you cannot
in a heated moment bring that up that's
not helpful
that's not supportive um
afterwards right you'll go to breakfast
you go have lunch
and you talk about the fight and you say
hey i didn't like what i said
um i got frustrated
but i need you to not weaponize the past
again
and you said you forgive me you said we
put that stuff down i'm living this new
life i've recommitted to our
relationship we're two years away from
that stuff now
let's continue to move forward and at
some point both of you have to put those
bricks down and stop
using them to burden yourselves or stop
using them as weapons or you just need
to go your separate ways
right and i'm not a fan of that at all
it sounds like you've reconciled it and
y'all are back in the same place but
picking up old bricks to throw them at
each other it does nobody any good
it just leaves bloody broken messes
so if he even if he has forgiven me like
obviously this hurt
is still you know itself maybe
more fresh in his mind than than nomi
would like it to be is that something
where he needs to go see a counselor by
himself was it
would it be more beneficial for us to
see a counselor together you know we've
had some sessions we've obviously been
through marriage counseling
you know for quite a while but you know
we took we haven't been to one for
probably a year now
or is that just something he needs to
work maybe i should give him the option
to work through himself or if he wants
me by his side
yeah i think asking him i think that's
being a supportive partner asking
him to um what he needs
what he would like right his role in
this deal yeah i think it's
i think you're a year out after
something that was tough for both of you
um whatever it works it you all
experience it as tough so
a year out yeah go get a tune-up go
check in
let him know you didn't like the way
that fight ended you didn't like stuff
coming up from a couple of years ago
that you thought you were both past
you sound like you need help forgiving
you and you're still like to go back
to the backyard and pick up old bricks
and carry them around to the front yard
every once in a while
we all do that when i get sleepy and i
haven't been eating well
and i'm having moments of shame and
self-doubt
i'll think of things i said when i was
14 that i wish i could have back
and i'm an old man now and and i i don't
know where those things come from but
they pop up and i've got to be
really diligent about controlling my
thoughts and my behaviors and not giving
them head space
to dwell and to take root again but your
husband's got to go do some work for
himself
you mentioned he's got past
relationships where he's got challenges
um he obviously ran into some trust
issues with you
he didn't like the way you were handling
yourself which and let's be honest i
don't blame him
right if he's working nights he's
feeling like he's supporting you he's
supporting this family he's trying to
grow this new house
and you basically started dating again
you didn't you didn't cheat on him you
didn't
um uh do anything that violated the
letter of the law there
but for whatever reason he was
uncomfortable with you having a bunch of
guy friends and going to bars and going
to play and going to hanging out and
going to movies which again i don't
blame him but at the same time sound
like you talk to you y'all
work it out you forgave each other you
went and got counseling and now you've
moved on to this new life
and so i don't want to belabor the point
but at some point he's gonna have to go
through the work to get whole too
because he's still hanging on to stuff
and this is a broader conversation for
everybody
this idea that once you forgive
something and you look somebody in the
eye
and you say i am done i forgive you
i am giving you pardon
or you've made um you've paid your
penance
we're back together here to pick that
back up and hit somebody with that is
just violence it just doesn't make any
sense it doesn't
help you it doesn't heal them i do
understand saying things when you get
frustrated when you get sad and you get
upset
when your patience and your wisdom and
your exhaustion
thins out your decision-making ability
things pop out i get that
um but don't bring up stuff from the
past just to abuse folks with don't do
that
don't do that and if you feel yourself
doing it if you feel yourself that
becoming your default setting
you know this is the third night this
week the dishes are out
just like that time three years ago
don't do that don't do that
because that becomes your issue not
theirs and by the way
katie it wouldn't surprise me if there's
behaviors going on in your heart
if there's a distance a small gap a
wedge between the two of you that may be
establishing itself again
that he feels that he's beginning to
feel this tension this pull apart
and maybe i'm making that up i'd love to
talk to him so at some point but
man leaning back into connection with
him taking him out this weekend and
saying i did not like the fight we had
i'm sorry for the role i played but wow
when you brought up that stuff from two
years ago that hurt
where did that come from why is that
still there
i think that'd be wise i think that'd be
wise you re reconnecting katie